find me when you wake
up speaking to film School rejects
screenwriter Christopher mccy said in
2014's Edge of Tomorrow the filmmakers
struggled to find a place in the film
for cage and Rita to kiss but nothing
they tried seemed genuine he said it
always felt false it always felt like
they weren't focused on what was really
important mccy and his colleagues gave
up on the kiss completely but apparently
blunt hadn't mccy said that as they shot
a scene in which Rita says goodbye to
cage blunt just kissed him goodbye in
the moment and it was not in the script
it was not even discussed according to
mcy after the scene was filmed blunt
said it just felt right it felt right
and I did it